Bitte schön.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Salih. Ich bin heute stationals.
Dann würde ich gerne mit Ihnen ein Anamnesigesprecht bücheln.
Ich stelle es klar.
Du musst sagen, kein Problem.
Ob das jemand guckt nach mir?
Genau.
Sollte ich gerne ein paar Fragen, bis ich Ihre persönlichen Daten stellen
und dann komme ich gleich zu Ihrer aktuellen Beschwerden.
Genau.
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Magdalena Schmidt.
Und Schmidt mit 2 T am Ende.
Okay. Können Sie Ihren Vornamen büchtern?
Auch nach mir.
Ja. M, A, G, D, A, D, A, L, I, N, A.
Magdalena. Genau.
Trausche mit, ne?
Trausche mit, genau.
Wie alt sind Sie bitte?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
56 Jahre alt, genau.
Wie alt sind Sie geworden?
Am 11.6.67.
67, genau.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,68 m und wiegeln 79 kg.
1,68?
60.
Schwer?
79 kg.
79, genau.
Okay. Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen heute?
Was fühlt es zu?
Ja, also mein rechter Arm ist seit ein paar Tagen ganz stark angeschwollen
und das wird immer mehr.
Und es tut jetzt so weh.
Der ist auch so ein bisschen gerötet und fühlt sich ganz warmer.
Und ich hab das Gefühl, ist das spannend
und dass ich den auch gar nicht richtig bewegen kann.
Okay.
Vor zwei Tagen hat es schon angefangen, ne?
Ja, seit zwei, drei Tagen ist das.
Und es wird halt immer mehr.
Und zur Arm Oberarm.
Nein, eigentlich, also der Oberarm und dann geht es runter bis, bis fast zu einem, würde ich sagen.
Genau.
Auch gibt es Schmerzen?
Bitte?
Auch gibt es Schmerzen auch?
Ja, ja, also das ist so ein Druckschmerz, der da drin ist, ja.
Wie stark die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzfalle von 1 bis 10, wenn 1 erlaubt, ist das 10 sehr stark.
Also ich würde schon sagen über die Hälfte, also das klingt nicht schon eins,
wird sagen 6, bei 6 sind die Schmerzen.
Was denke ich?
Die Schmerzen sind drückend, Sie haben gesagt...
Drückend, ja, würde ich am, am Essen sagen, ja.
Genau.
Haben Sie verletzt oder etwas haben Sie bemerkt, bevor ich...
Ich weiß nicht, dass ich mich verletzt habe. Nein.
Ich habe auch in die Job gekauft.
Okay.
Hat es sich schon mal endlich erwischt werden oder seit zwei Tagen erst mal?
Also sowas habe ich noch nie gehabt, dass ich solche Beschwerden hatte.
Mhm, verstehe.
Fächer purin ist auch taubheitsgefühl, arm Eisenauf...
Nee, taubheitsgefühl habe ich da eigentlich nicht.
Nee, nur eben nur dieses Gefühl, dass das geschwollen ist und, und,
dass ich eben diesen Druckschmerz habe.
Mhm, genau.
Wie sind die Oberarm und uns haben, wie ist Schunzer gerötet?
Ja, so ein bisschen gerötet ist das ja.
Also bist du schulterlich, aber der Oberarm ist gerötet, ja.
Und auch die Finger sind so ein bisschen geschwollen.
Mhm.
Das geht bis in die Finger noch ein.
Verstehe.
Und ich habe eben das Gefühl, dass der Arm auch schwer ist und dass ich den gar nicht gut bewegen kann.
Ich mache jetzt im Augenblick alles mit links, ne?
Bewegungs-Einschränkung, Einschränkung, auch haben es, oder?
Ja, genau.
Mhm.
Okay.
Gib mir jetzt bestimmte Auslöser, die Sie bemerkt haben oder etwas?
Ich kann mich überhaupt nicht erinnern.
Also wie gesagt, ich habe keine Verletzung an der Hand und an dem Arm.
Und ich kann mir das eigentlich nicht richtig erklären.
Mhm.
Bevor die Beschwerden aufgetreten sind, haben sie keinen Verletzung gehabt.
Auch keine, vielleicht etwas, habe sie bemerkt nie.
Also jetzt davor direkt nicht, nein.
Okay, das stimmt.
Leidien Sie auch unser Luftnot oder verspüren Sie Fieber?
Fieber weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe nicht gemessen, da könnte es schon sein.
Ich fühle mich so ein bisschen warm.
Aber Luftnot nötig.
Mhm.
Okay.
Ich habe es etwas dagegen gemacht.
Ja, also ich habe versucht, den Arm irgendwie ein bisschen ruhig zu halten.
Ich habe es auch mal ein bisschen gekühlt, aber das hat irgendwie auch nicht viel gebracht.
Mhm.
Bei der Hochlage, ähm, verbessern, verbessern, die schmerzen sich.
Ja, also wenn ich nachts habe, ich hätte mir ein Kissen darunter gelügt.
Und die ist ein bisschen besser, ja.
Mhm.
Dadurch konnte ich in der Nacht wenigstens ein bisschen schlafen, ja.
Ähm, haben Sie bisher unter vielleicht Gefäß, unter Gefäßverängung oder Gefäßprobleme
gehabt oder gelitten?
Nein, aber das Einzige, was wirklich einschleiten war, ich hatte so eine Brustoperation vor 4 Jahren.
Aber das ist schon lange her.
Was für eine Brustoperation haben Sie ja noch?
Ja, ich hatte ein Brustkrebs, ne?
Mhm.
Und auf der rechten Seite ist das eben operativ versorgt worden.
Und das ist aber 14 Jahre her.
Vor 14 Jahren.
Mhm.
Haben Sie auch Schitalo, Therapie, der Kommen?
Nee, ich habe diese Brustopie bekommen und dann habe ich kurze Zeit Chemotherapie
bekommen, aber keine Schalung.
Ähm, leiden Sie auch andere Vorerkrankungen auf?
Bitte, was?
Leiden Sie andere Vorerkrankungen, wie Brutoph, du?
Ja, man hat damals, im Zusammenhang, als ich da so krank war, hat man eben festgestellt,
dass ich auch ein bisschen hohe Blutdruck habe.
Und vor ein paar Jahren hat man festgestellt, dass ich auch so erhöhte
Schikolesterinwerte habe.
Wann war das, das genau?
Oh, das ist, lassen Sie mich überlegen, das ist vor 9 Jahren her.
Mhm.
Ähm, Brutzochdruck, Sie haben gesagt vor ein paar Jahren, was war das?
Ja, das ist, also damals im Rahmen dieser, dieser Brustkrebsoperation,
hat man festgestellt, dass der Blutdruck auch ein bisschen hohe ist.
Was nehmen Sie gegen Brutdruck ein?
Ja, ich nehme Konko 5 und die Ovan 160.
Die Ovan?
Mhm.
Und das?
160.
Mhm, 160.
Ähm, besuchen Sie Ihr Haus, Ihr Haus oder Ihr Hausessen regelmäßig?
Ja, eigentlich bin ich da schon ziemlich regelmäßig um den Kontrollen.
Nehmen Sie etwas auch gegen erhöhte Schikolesterinwerte?
Nein, da nehme ich eigentlich nichts ein.
Da versuche ich so ein bisschen über die Ernährung,
dass ich vorsichtig esse und jetzt nicht gerade so
kolesterinbocken zu mir nehme.
Aber sonst mache ich da nix, ich nehme da keine medikamente ein.
Äh, außer dass Sie wegen Brustkrebs operiert wurden,
auch haben Sie eine Operation gehabt?
Eine Anrealität, ja.
Vor einem Jahr habe ich auf der rechten Seite den neuen SÜVT-Gelenk bekommen.
Mhm, die Operationen waren komplikationlos?
Ja.
Okay.
Sind Sie diese Beschwerden bei einem Arzt?
Nein, nein, das ist mir jetzt nur heute Abend ein bisschen unheimlich geworden,
weil der Arm überhaupt nicht besser wird.
Und deswegen bin ich dann hier gleich direkt in die Klinik gekommen.
Mhm, genau.
Aber normalerweise besuchen die wegen der Brustkrebs,
ihrer Shirok oder Shirolgin.
Ich war da beim Genug von Google und da gehe ich auch regelmäßig
zur Kontrolle natürlich und beim Hausarzt, wenn ich regelmäßig war.
Ich entdehren Sie daran, dass beide Operationen auch
Luftknoten unter Achselhöhe und die
Schuhe zu machen.
Und das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Mhm, ja, okay.
Okay, genau.
Haben Sie auch Stuflost?
Ich habe sie in letzter Zeit geblieben,
Verlust oder Abnahmen bemerkt?
Nein, ich würde gerne ein bisschen abnehmen, aber das klappt nicht.
Ja, verstanden.
Gibt es Schwierigkeiten bei Masalast und Stubank?
Nein, das ist eigentlich alles ganz normal.
Mhm, genau.
Besuchen Sie auch wegen Vor-Sor-Grunden-Suchen
Ihren Hausarzt und Ihren Hausärzt
wegen der gynecologischen Vor-Sor-Grunden-Suchen?
Nein, da gehe ich zum gynecologischen Tor,
regelmäßigen Vor-Sor-Grunden-Suchen.
Ja, okay.
Einmal im Jahr.
Das ist ja alles schon lange her, ne?
Wann war das? Letzter Mal?
Ja, die letzte gynecologische Untersuchung ist 3 Monate.
Aber diese Krebserkrankung, das liegt ja schon 14 Jahre zurück.
Ja, ja, ich verstehe genau.
Darf ich fragen, ob Ihre Eltern im Leben sind?
Mein Vater lebt nicht mehr.
Und meine Mutter lebt noch, die ist natürlich hoch betragt,
aber die hat ein bisschen Bluthochdruck
und hat auch ein neues Hüft gelegt,
aber sonst ist sie eigentlich relativ fit für ihr Alter.
Und mein Vater, der ist sehr früh gestorben.
Der hatte einen Herzinfarkt mit 50.
Mit 50?
Ja, er ist mehr leid.
Haben Sie Geschwister auch?
Ja, mein Bruder ist vor vier Jahren am Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Und meine Schwester, die ist ein bisschen jünger als ich,
weil der hat man vor einem Jahr auch Brustkrebs festgestellt leider.
Ist mir leid.
Ich sehe auch, würde ihr auch operiert?
Sie ist auch operiert worden bis jetzt in der Nachbehandlung.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Leben Sie mit Ihrem Mann?
Ja, wir leben mit der Familie, wobei die Kinder sind natürlich groß.
Ich bin zu groß, Mutter, und wir sehen uns aber häufiger.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Ein Sohn und zwei Tochter.
Ein Sohn, zwei Tochter, sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ich hoffe doch.
Was machen Sie von Büro?
Ich arbeite im Reisebüro, ich bin Reiseverkehrskaufraub.
Sind Sie damit zufrieden oder gibt es Schwierigkeiten bei der Arbeit?
Nein, eigentlich ist das ganz schön.
Das war eine mühsame Zeit, als wir praktisch nichts verkaufen konnten.
Das war eine Corona-Zeit, als niemand verreist ist, aber jetzt laufen die Geschäfte wieder gut.
Das ist natürlich erfreulich.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, natürlich bin ich vollständig geimpft.
Darf ich fragen, ob Sie verhüteten oder wie Sie verhüteten?
Ja, ich bin schon in der Menopause.
Brauchen Sie?
Nee, gerauft habe ich noch nie.
Ist das richtig?
Ich trinke wieder mein Glas Wein, wenn es ein Glas Sekt gibt oder ein ganz tolles Cocktail oder so bei Trockenen Begelegenheiten.
Kann ich mir sagen, die Besündung lassen?
Ja, kann man sagen.
Was trinke ich jetzt ganz genau?
Ich trinke gerne ein Glas Wein oder ein Glas Sekt.
und wieder auch mal, wenn es welche gibt, die gut gemixt sind, trinke ich auch gerne Cocktails.
Cocktails, okay. Darf ich dich fragen, ob Sie bisher Kontakt zu Drogen gehabt haben?
Mit Drogen? Oh nee, da habe ich noch nie Kontakt gehabt. Sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas?
So viel ich weiß, gibt es keine Allergien. Ich habe so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen
Heuschluften im Frühling, dass ich dann so, wenn die Polen fliegen, dass ich so ein bisschen
eine Schnuffnase habe, aber ich würde es nicht als Allergien bezeichnen.
Mhm.
Ja. Auch Leidensunds-Unfertechlichkeiten.
Was meinen Sie mit Unverschräglichkeiten?
Vielleicht gegen Laktosintoleranz. Wie Laktosintoleranz.
Nein, nein, also Essen und Trinken kann ich alles eigentlich.
Ja, das führt mich. Okay.
Ich mag nur nicht alles.
Ja.
Genau.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, also seit Monaten nicht mehr, nein.
Mhm. Genau.
Sie haben bemerkt, dass innerhalb drei Tagen ihr angeschworen ist und gerotet ist.
Ja.
Genau. Das ist Flösterangefangen. Das hat Flösterangefangen.
Und auch haben Sie Schmerzen, ne?
Ja, ja. Das ist spannend und drückt.
Genau. Das ist schmerzhaft, ja.
Ja. Aber bei der Hochladung oder beim Fühlen?
Ja, so ein bisschen besser wird es dann dabei.
Ich biste auch etwas, dass die Schmerzen verschlechtert?
Oder?
Na ja, also das macht man eigentlich automatisch.
Wenn ich das belasten würde jetzt, ich denke, das würde die Schmerzen verschlechtert.
Ich habe den Arm jetzt einfach ein bisschen geschont, ja.
Weil ich gemerkt habe, wenn ich irgendwas mache, dann tut es wie.
Ich würde jetzt damit keine schwere Tasche tragen oder...
Ja, für ich wäre das nicht.
Nicht mal die Zähne putzen, ja.
Ich putze mir die Zähne mit der linken Hand.
Das geht ganz schlecht, ja.
Aber recht würde ich das nicht machen.
Ja, das ist nachvollziehbar.
Genau.
Normalerweise wollte ich auch eine Prachtung auf der Grafige.
Genau, ich bin am Ende mit meinem Gespräch.
Ich würde jetzt die Körper nicht untersuchen,
Blut abnehmen, sie müssen hierbleiben,
bis wir alle Ergebnisse gesammelt haben
und eine richtige Diagnose schättern.
Genau.
Aber ich muss nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben, ne?
Ehrlich gesagt, kann ich jetzt nicht genauer sagen,
bevor ich eine richtige Diagnose stelle.
Ja, also hoffentlich ist es nicht so was Schöne,
dass ich im Krankenhaus bleiben muss.
Ich hoffe auch, aber es könnte sein,
vieler, dass eine Gerinsil mit Oberarm
ist, sein könnte.
Und das könnte auslösen,
eine Schwellung im Arm.
Aber es könnte auch eine Hautentschuldung sein,
aber zuerst muss ich ein paar andere Massnahmen durchführen.
Und dann kann ich...
Okay, dann gucken wir hinterher bis weiter.
Ja, alles klar.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere Fragen?
Ja.
Von irgendwo kam ein überzeugendes Ja.
Wer hat noch eine Frage?
Kollegen?
Okay, kein Punkt.
Strahlung nicht gefragt.
Bitte was?
Ausstrahlung.
Ausstrahlung, ah ja.
Also, sie hat ja gesagt, es geht
vom Oberarm in den ganzen Arm bis in die Hand.
Wobei die Schwellung eben auch die Hand mit,
die Finger mit betrifft.
Und Infektionstik nicht gefragt.
Infektionstik?
Ja, es ist vom Nünke-Infekt.
Und könnte es zum Beispiel Infektstik...
Ah, ein Insekt-Instich.
Ja, ist nicht...
Insekt-Instich. Ja, es ist jetzt die Saison.
Die Westen sind da.
Und die Mücken kommen wieder.
Ist eine gute Idee, ja.
Aber sie hat keine Verletzung bemerkt.
Und sie hat auch keinen Insekt-Instich bemerkt.
Und Yukreis...
Nee, Jucken tut es nicht.
Okay.
Stellfrost...
Ja, hat er gefragt, habe ich verneint.
Stellfrost hat er gefragt, ja.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Oh ja. Hallo.
Ja, auf welcher Seite, welche Brust wurden Sie operiert?
Rechts.
Und haben Sie eine kleine offene Wunde zum Beispiel in der Nagel?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Als Jentin hat es nicht bemerkt, das wäre etwas,
wo nach der Doktor jetzt gleich in der Untersuchung forschen musste.
Ob es da etwas gibt.
Genau.
Danke.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestalten...
Ich denke auch, ja.
Könnten wir Arztheitsgeschichte anfangen?
Sie gucken wenig begeistert, Herr Doktor Sali.
Ich bin begeistert, aber ich bin proprio begeistert.
Gut, wir probieren.
Ja, genau.
Ich war nachdenklich, wie ich gut vorstellen kann.
Sie waren nachdenklich, Sie haben überlegt,
wie Sie das gut präsentieren können.
Sie haben nachgedacht, wie man das übermachen kann.
Ja, genau.
Dann schauen wir mal, zu welchem Ergebnis Sie gekommen sind.
Okay, ich auch mehr mal.
Guten Abend, Frau Bertsen.
Ich würde gerne eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Darf ich?
Ja, natürlich.
Wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Ich habe Frau Schmidt gesehen.
Frau Schmidt ist eine 56-Jährige, 1,68 Meter große
und 79 schwerer Patientin.
Kilospherer?
Kilogramm schwerer Patientin.
Nicht Kilogramm, das heißt...
Ach so.
Eigentlich ist richtig Kilogramm.
Ja, okay.
Das ist die offizielle Einheit.
Haiko und andere Tutor, gesagt alle Kilo.
Ja, wir sagen natürlich Kilo.
Aber offiziell ist Kilogramm eigentlich schon die richtige Einheit.
Aber jedenfalls nicht 79 schwer, sondern 79 kilo schwer.
Die sich heute bei uns wegen seit 3 Tagen bestehende,
progredierende...
Progredierende, oder progredierende, was wollen Sie sagen?
Progredierende.
Okay, ja, danke.
Es geht so weiter.
Ein Erditeimatöse ödeim,
rechts in Oberarm,
rechts in Oberarm.
Das ist die erste Art.
Die erste Art.
Das ist Mon short.
Die er hatrika Columbus önemli.
Ein Erditeimatose ödeim
Links in Oberarm,
vorgestellt.
Zweitens geschützt,
seniorer,
bei 8 auf einen nummerischen Reitstekala, 6, 8, 6, 8 und keine Plexi, für dich Plexi, Fiba, aber nicht gemessen.
Bei 8 Regenwürde hat gemeint, dass die Schmerzen bei den Hoflegeren verbessert sind.
Die Bewegung von Einschränkungen auf den rechten Arm.
Als Feuerkrankungen leidet sie an Artiller Hypopathonie seit 14 Jahren und an Hypocholesterinämie.
Dagegen nehmen sie Konko 5 Milligramm, Dioban 160 Milligramm,
Sie hat nicht gesagt, dass sie eine komplette Masseitomie hatte.
Heute operieren wir sehr auf Brust erhalten und in diesem Fall unterstellen.
Sie hat also eine Mammarkatzinom, die brusterhaltend operiert wurde.
Als Operationen hat sie gemeint, dass sie vor 14 Jahren wegen Mammarkatzinom operiert wurde.
Aber sie hat gesagt, dass sie keine Traurtherapie, keine Traurtherapie, keine Radiation bekommen habe.
Außerdem wurde bei ihr vor 3 Monaten eine rechte Hüfte gelenkt,
Wir sagen, dass es eine Hüfte gibt.
Und durchgeführt.
Er ist in der Familie am Nest, erinnert, dass ihr Fazah am Mammarkatinfaktur verstorben seid.
Ich habe an Arzile Hypocholesterinämie gelitzt.
Sie leidet immer noch, sie lebt ja noch.
Sie leidet uns an Arzile Hypocholesterinämie.
Bei ihr wurde auch eine 50-Gerlechoperation gemacht.
Ich habe auch eine Mammarkatinfaktur gehabt.
Sie lebt noch.
Sie lebt in der Familie am Nest.
Sie lebt am Mammarkatinfaktur verstorben.
Sie lebt noch.